[Music]
a deadly crush of humanity trying to
escape afghanistan
the uk is desperate to avoid a repeat of
these scenes from the weekend
but as the clock ticks down on a
deadline set by the united states for
troops to leave and for this evacuation
to end
what one source described as a cliff
edge looms larger
high stakes for all involved
i don't think there is any likelihood on
staying on after the united states
if their timetable extends even by day
or two then that will give us a day or
two more to evacuate people because we
are really down to hours
now not weeks and we have to
make sure we exploit every minute to get
people out at kabul airport british and
u.s troops work together to control the
crowd
but there's tension back home between
london and washington over the crisis
u.s forces are set to withdraw by the
31st of august it means the uk and other
allies must go too with evacuation
flights ending even sooner
unless that is britain's prime minister
can convince president joe biden to
delay his exit plans at a virtual g7
meeting tomorrow
until then no change possible i'm not
going to speculate about uh post august
31st we are head down focused on keeping
these numbers up as best we can getting
as many people out as we can by the end
of the month and if there needs to be
a discussion about extending that
timeline
then we absolutely will have that
discussion at the appropriate time with
the commander-in-chief
and don't forget it's not just the us
calling the shots anymore afghanistan's
new taliban leaders also have a say and
are openly hostile to the idea
you can say it's a red line president
biden
announced
this agreement that until uh 31st of
august they would withdraw all their
military forces
so if they extend it that means they are
extending occupation while there is no
need for for that i think that it will
deteriorate the relation that will uh
create mistrust between us if they are
intent on continuing the occupation so
it will
provoke reaction
then there's a growing security threat
from islamic state the longer the
evacuation goes on it's a chaotic exit
and it's straining the uk's special
relationship with the us
cut out from biden's decision to leave
can boris johnson secure a few extra
days on the ground
it's a matter of life and death for
those waiting
debra haines sky news